[Music]
[Laughter]
i think i thought that was a stroke of
genius on my part
it was really good i was just kind of
like cause i like that little song that
i got from like a
uh a free music site and i was like oh
you know what this needs it needs a
little microwave dang at the end that
would be super funny
yeah so we went out last night so we're
kind of we're still kind of thrashed
from last night we had a good time
so i i was going to do like she's like
well we got to stream something
what's going on well it's got to be
something that something that's relevant
but something's kind of simple
all right so it's gonna be a fast one
he's gonna pull the fats on this is
gonna be a fast one you can make ice
cream
we used to make ice cream all the time
when i was a kid in the south but we had
these ice cream makers
and you put it had you it was like a
bucket inside of a bucket and on the
outer bucket you put in a bunch of ice
cubes and a bunch of rock salt
it's a bunch of inception yeah and then
you put you put
bucception and then you put that's like
some chuck tingle [ __ ]
and then then you put hold on let me
adjust my hat now
she's got me laughing already i'm gonna
[ __ ] go all willy wonka
[ __ ] all right so
what's so funny so [ __ ] fun
she wants to start laughing and [ __ ] man
she doesn't understand how serious this
is clearly very scary
yeah so you put the ice
and the rock salt in between the little
bucket and the big bucket sometimes this
[ __ ] was all [ __ ]
fancy you know i mean the way it would
all come apart and then you put your
ice cream mix which is basically
cream milk eggs bunch of sugar
vanilla whatever chocolate or whatever
and uh
fruit and then uh you put a paddle in
there and you had this big electric
motor you put on top and you plugged it
in
and it churned it probably i guess about
15-20 minutes later it turned into ice
cream that [ __ ] was [ __ ] good
all right yeah now if you thought you
were saving money making this ice cream
no that should cost about twice what it
would take
to get it from a big creamery you know
or just buy it pre-made you know
but you could make some bizarre ass
flavors like orange ice cream
not orange sherbet orange ice cream
yeah which is kind of a different thing
yeah totally and it's it's good
all right um so and you could make
peanut butter ice cream which i imagine
sandra would be all about that
peanut butter ice cream it's real good
so you can make all kinds of crazy
flavors of ice cream one of the ones
that you could do though
and that's what we're going to talk
about in here is instead of making that
damn
ice cream mix you know what i mean you
could just pour eggnog in it
in the machine and run it and that would
turn into [ __ ]
uh that would turn into ice cream eggnog
ice cream yeah well there you go
because all the stuff started in there
right well
the smell you can even eliminate that
machine so that's what we're going to
talk about today you don't really need
that machine
you could put a bit of a small bowl
inside of a bigger bowl
and then use an electric mixer okay like
a you know with the egg beater
on you know and and that'll turn in into
uh ice cream also
and uh but i'll take it even one step
simpler than that
you can take a you can take a one quart
plastic ziploc bag a good one
and pour eggnog into it
get all the air out of it so you just
got a little bag of eggnog
and throw that into a one gallon ziploc
bag
and in that bag you put about three cups
of damn ice
and some rock salt and just shake it
about 15 minutes later maybe 20 minutes
later probably about 15 minutes
it will start to turn into ice cream you
pull that little bag out
and cut the corner off of it squeeze it
out like a pastry bag into
into bowls and you'd have some soft
serve yeah it's like soft soft serve
eggnog ice cream now so many people in
other countries are like what the [ __ ]
is egg dog
[Laughter]
egg dog's a holiday drink we would drink
and sometimes you'd put rum in it or
you know bourbon and you or you could
just drink it straight and how to make
that [ __ ]
yes boy it's easy but it's not healthy
at all
it's one cup of in general you can alter
you can you can change the ratios a
little bit
in general for
it for every one cup of milk there's
also
one whole egg in it yeah
and about a quarter cup of sugar
a little bit of vanilla and a little bit
of vanilla
extract and a little bit of
nutmeg and then all you do is just mix
it
yeah i like your gestures yeah and it'll
turn into a yellowish kind of thick
sweet drink tastes like melted ice cream
with with uh
with nutmeg in it it's looking good well
that's the basis for
for ice cream you know what i mean eggs
milk sugar
now there's even easier way to do it in
that bag you can just use about a cup
you could just
use about a cup a half and half you
don't need the eggs
put some granulated sugar in it and a
little bit of vanilla extract or
chocolate
um syrup in it and put that in a ziploc
bag and shake it and that'll turn into
ice cream too but it would be kind of
like a
kind of tastes kind of like a low-fat
ice cream you know what i mean because
it doesn't have the eggs and no one
likes that
eggs give it the stretchiness yeah you
know that richness
so do you have a uh
uh uh actual uh vanilla ice cream recipe
over there i have an eggnog ice cream
okay go ahead and i'm imagining that's
the same but this is uh what it's
telling you to do
okay it says uh two cups heavy cream
yeah
ten ounces uh sweetened condensed milk
oh okay all right so they're gonna go
that way
two cups of eggnog okay uh three-quarter
teaspoon cinnamon
so you put eggnog so he's got eggnog in
it
yeah so he's enriched eggnog with
contested milk
like cream in the [ __ ] so he's noggin
that the [ __ ] out
okay all right yeah three quarters of a
teaspoon of cinnamon
okay three quarters of a teaspoon of
nutmeg okay and uh
bourbon whiskey or okay if you want so
he's got alcohol in it
yeah well it's optional yeah um and he's
putting it he's doing without a machine
too he's putting in a big mixing bowl or
a stand mixer
yeah um and then you beat the cream
until you get stiff peaks
that sounds dirty yeah then you blend in
peaks
both the one on the right and the left
good
go ahead i just had to come off okay
okay uh then you blend in
the condensed milk the eggnog the
cinnamon and the nutmeg
then you can put in the liquor if you
want it yeah and then you basically pour
it into like a big bread loaf pan
or a freezer safe dish and you freeze it
for about four hours
okay and then you got your eggnog ice
cream
okay so basically like i said you don't
really need the ice cream maker
i don't know where people got the idea
that you had to have that because they
sold them
well yeah i mean we made ice cream in
those before and it was like really cool
and everything but it's like you can
easily like you said you can just make
it in like a bag or
in a stand mixer or in two bowls or in
two bowls or whatever and you just kind
of put it in a big metal loaf pan and
stick it in the freezer
yeah if you've got big mixing bowls like
i got a whole set of those metal mixing
bowls like
if you had an extra i got like a [ __ ]
big extra large one and i also got a
smaller size that'll fit in that
that's all you'd need yeah you could
just line it with rock salt and ice
put the little bowl in there pour your
pour your ice cream mixture in there and
just hit it with a
machine and then you're gonna use a damn
spatula to get it all out of there or
you can
and put it into another container like a
little bucket with a lid or
you know or something put it in the
freezer you know like a
tupperware with a lid something like
that
and they also have a thing uh this other
article i saw that so you can also make
it in like a mason jar
yeah if you wanted to yeah that sounds
like that it's the same kind of thing
it's the same principle as the bag you
just put everything in the jar and shake
it all up
right and then you freeze it for about
two hours so it's the same kind of [ __ ]
yeah some some restaurants these french
restaurants were doing that same basic
thing instead of using rock salt and
everything they're using the dry ice
because that's pretty cold too
yeah that's another way to do it yeah
that's right if you you know using dry
ice
and it it happens a little bit faster
and then you shake it and you take the
you take the uh com you take the little
jar out of the dry ice bucket
and and evidently it'll dry ice will
last a long time and you can make single
servings of ice cream
now in some of these recipes just in a
general
uh you know in general they're adding
sugar because they're talking about
vanilla
if you're going to add a chocolate that
already has a bunch of sugar in there
you might want to back off on the damn
sugar
because it's going to be in the
chocolate and by the same
token same thing with the these fruits
a lot of times in a kitchen somebody's
just taking frozen like i do it all the
time they'll take some frozen berries
and pour sugar on them and put them in a
in a container
and just shake it and let it sit and
it'll kind of cure and turn into ice
cream topping
yeah with the syrup and everything now
when you do that it's
sugar in there and a couple splashes of
lemon juice that lemon juice will bring
the tart out
it'll be sweet but it'll be tart like
sweet tart yeah you want both and you
can you can adjust it to taste
but really it's hard to over tartan
things like berries
well sometimes that's kind of been done
well now i guess sometimes that's
already been done in like
canned versions of berries like in the
pie fillings and stuff
okay like blackberry pie filling or
raspberry pie filling [ __ ] like that
it probably already has a tarting agent
like a like um
like lemon it's already got sugar in it
you could just
add that right into that cream and make
ice cream directly
with that yeah that's right i never
thought of that yeah you could do that
yeah and it's the same thing with like
canned peaches
that makes real good ice cream that's
what my grandma always used to make in
the ice cream maker she always made
peach ice cream because it was kind of
hard to get back then
like they only had it in the summertime
yeah so you know the south was really
big on
canned peaches and just having peaches
around peaches were a southern thing
and uh if you're gonna make ice cream
you have peaches might as well put the
peaches in it yeah it comes out great
comes out real good well
inside that inside that can
is going to have some syrup and
you might want to cut back on some of
the sugar in the recipe
because you're going to add some or all
of that damn peach
juice in there because it's got that
peach flavor
and it's already got sugar in it okay
and that'll be part of the ice cream too
but you have to
you have to know what you're doing it
might the first couple times you make
this you may not get it exactly right
might be too much liquid in it or
something but
you will be able to figure out how to
make decent ice creams of the
consistency you want out of the things
that you have
it just might take a couple times to get
it right
um if i were going to use canned peaches
and some of the syrup that came out of
the canned peaches i'd add lemon to it
i'd make it a little bit tart because
there's already going to be sugar and
cream in there and everything and you're
going to want that
lemon flavor to pop you know you don't
want it to be sickly sweet you want it
to have kind of a tart
fruit flavor kind of come out of it and
that's always lemon
always yeah and you i would do that with
for apples too
you could probably make an apple ice
cream be really good well i wonder why
you don't really see apple ice cream
you think that you would think i mean
apple doesn't have a super super strong
flavor maybe that's why
well what i would do is i'd try
something kind of like
apple pie filling yeah all right
something
how that comes in a damn can because
they eat vanilla ice cream
and apple pie yeah that's a good
combination it's got the
the the the cinnamon in it and the sugar
already
maybe add a little bit of um lemon
lemon juice to that can and stir it a
little bit and then pour it in there
pour it into vanilla ice cream yeah that
might be and you may not even
actually have to add the vanilla there
may be enough flavor
in in that can of
apple pie filling to make that taste
like apple ice cream
yeah yeah it might not you just have to
see it now that i'm thinking about that
so i'm saying
you got to be creative with this [ __ ]
think it out i mean you can ice cream
pretty much you can ice cream anything
because you know it's such a blank slate
i was thinking maybe now that i'm
thinking about i don't think i've ever
seen an
apple ice cream no but i think i have
seen like a special edition apple pie
ice cream because it had the same thing
i would say cinnamon it had like bits of
crust in it it's because they're
thinking the same thing i'm thinking
yeah i'm like lex luthor with this
otisville i'm a [ __ ] over in
otisville mr luffa
oh my god okay how are you doing mr
luthor
duh and i've seen also i think i've seen
a key lime pie ice cream as well yeah
which i'm sure that
would be that's really good and i'm
trying to think you know what i
know what i think would be good for
these single serving or small
serving of ice creams would be like a
can of them damn
mandarin oranges oh yeah yeah the look
with the little magic maybe break them
up a little bit
and put them in there yeah along with
that juice
that'd probably be really good because
you really you really like uh fruit ice
cream
fruit we talk about this a lot because
he really likes fruit
ice cream and he really likes fruit
candy yeah
all that kind of stuff and i'm kind of
more like a chocolate and nut kind of
person
that's a lot easier for ice cream you
know
to do that just add chocolate syrup to
it yeah don't don't put
um or coffee i would like to actually
make some
some coffee ice cream well with coffee
ice cream and i would make vanilla ice
cream and then just add like
folger's instant coffee crystals to it
well yeah that's what i was thinking
about doing yeah
that's what i would do i mean i break it
down a little bit of water first a
couple tablespoons of water
and turn it into like a real dark black
slurry and pour that in there
yeah and mix it again yeah until you get
the color right
you don't want it to be too dark
although real strong might be good
yeah usually when you buy and i really
like like the commercially available
coffee ice creams like
uh like blue bunny and all that yeah um
and those are kind of they're not super
dark
usually those have like little chocolate
chunks in there which is also nice yeah
i like that that's probably it's not my
favorite flavor i think my favorite
flavor is probably uh mint chocolate
chip
yeah but if you were gonna make that
vanilla ice cream in a bag
you could make it as regular vanilla ice
cream take a snicker bar and break that
up into chunks and throw that in there
and shake it you'd have a snickers ice
cream
and you could make that you know make it
a serving for two
you know or a serving for one it doesn't
take that long
just a little bit of planting and you
have to have the ingredients
and if you're making it that way
you might come ahead in terms of money
if it's just half and half
instead of the cream and the milk just
use half and half and
you could probably omit the eggs and
just and just put the sugar and candy in
it
that would be like a really bare bones
version of it because i've seen very
stripped down versions that
of homemade ice cream done in the bag
and that would only be a few cents
really
the biggest expense would be the candy
bar
that's true so i'm just thinking it from
the from the economical standpoint
it's hard to beat a three dollar damn
gallon of ice cream
that's pretty damn cheap there's a lot
of three dollar gallons of ice cream
after four dollar gallon of ice cream
and they're the flavors are [ __ ] good
what what is it a gallon of [ __ ]
um publix ice cream is what is it a
gallon or a pint i can't remember no
it's a gallon
they usually do if you go to publix they
usually have
um two for seven dollars so they're 350
each
and they have like a [ __ ] ton of flavors
and they're all
really good and real good i don't know
you have to yeah i really like it if you
were sourcing eggs
in big crates like we bought them from
publix yeah or not yeah not public
speaking
sam's where you get a big case you could
probably get the price down
because we use a lot of eggs and uh and
you're getting
you're buying sugar in bulk you could
probably uh
and and uh you know you can get
cream in bulk too from sam's
yeah big half gallon things of cream you
could probably
or you could like i said instead of
using cream and milk just getting half
and half
sometimes you can find that for a good
price you might be able to get it down a
little bit underneath
three dollars a gallon maybe i don't
know what you were making
yeah as long as you weren't making
anything that was like super fancy or
complicated like fillings
wise yeah but i don't know i just don't
know it's hard to say how much is a damn
gown
how much would a gallon of [ __ ] half
and half b
uh can't be because i i think
yeah yeah i think now and a half and a
half would probably be about
like i said i think maybe like big
companies that make it yeah are
you know that's economies of scale
you're just kind of making it at home
i mean it's good when it's made at home
but well
what's good is if you just want some ice
cream right away and you're just going
to make a bowl
yeah you can make it that way if you
have the rock salt and ice and if you if
you already have all the [ __ ]
you can make it real quick well like i
said it's you know i'm kind of more into
i like some fruit flavored ice creams
like i like um
man that uh memories of india that
restaurant we go to they make the
[ __ ]
best mango [ __ ] ice cream yeah and
they make it their in-house they told
you yes
god damn that's good and i don't even
like mangoes but that ice cream is
delicious yeah probably you but by the
texture and everything they're probably
using that most
dumbed down version where it's just half
and half
yeah half and half sugar and some kind
of fruit shake it
that's probably all and it's it's super
super smooth and it's really really
nicely blended like it's not like weird
it might have an egg in it you're right
because it does seem to kind of stretch
a little bit doesn't it yeah
it might have some little bit of eggs in
it you see like on those uh
cooking competition shows they have that
ice cream maker thing that's like built
into the wall you just make your mixture
and you pour it in there and then like a
few minutes later it comes out i don't
know if that's like got liquid nitrogen
in it or something
yeah because it seems like it does it
pretty quick
and you know and i've seen them on and
i've seen them on there making ice cream
with liquid nitrogen too like if they
were
trying to make ice cream and they were
like getting to the they were like
running out of time
so like they do it doesn't always work
but because you have to kind of be
careful with it
yeah thoughts on moose tracks i actually
really like those tracks i i like
i like ice creams that have like um you
know chunks of nuts or chunks of
chocolate
in it so i like you know what i mean i
like chunky ice cream i like butter
pecan like i said i like mint chocolate
chip i like coffee
with chocolate chips in it um that one
oh that one that's like vanilla or mint
ice cream that has
[ __ ] uh crumbled up thin mint girl
scout cookies in it that's fantastic i
love that [ __ ]
grandpa samer said some funny [ __ ] he
saw a southern bumper sticker one time
in north carolina
and it said give a yankee directions
point him north i saw that like like
when the back when my grandpa was still
alive
point that [ __ ] north that's like all
time ago
that's a long time ago yeah billy idol
said on an episode of viva la bam that
his diet that kept him thin was
strawberry haagen-dazs and heineken beer
[Laughter]
he didn't mention all that okay you know
yeah i was like i'm sure that helps yeah
i mean if if if all you had was ice
cream and beer and that was like you
just ate that every day and that was all
you had yeah i could see
state of the all that but yeah i'm sure
the cocaine probably can't heroin i'm
sure
yeah zach says mint chocolate chip ice
cream with some scoops of peanut butter
go beautifully together oh yeah i agree
with that i liked and we like to
sometimes if you just have vanilla ice
cream
i like to like melt a little bit of
peanut butter and like pour it on there
like a peanut butter
sauce yeah we're talking about peanut
butter ice cream you could probably use
whole peanut butter out of a jar but
nowadays if you go to like
walmart you'll find big i have some
big plastic jars of powdered peanut
butter it's a
it's a powder you can add water to it
and it'll become peanut butter or you
could
i put it in like protein shakes as a
flavoring really good
you could you could probably use that
damn powder in in an ice cream
yeah that might work better because it
would be easier to mix yeah it would
blend in there a lot more evenly
that's what i would use couple
tablespoons of that peanut butter powder
i kind of feel like if you're gonna go
that route then i would like some
crunched up peanuts in there too because
like i said yeah ketchup some peanuts
because i like
chunky like i said if we if we don't buy
ice cream that often
but um i mean sometimes if we just have
vanilla
then i like to put stuff in it i like to
pull with slivered almonds or like i
said a little bit of peanut butter
or some chocolate chips or whatever we
have like if we have anything in the
house
we almost always have nuts because we
buy like big bags of and i got nuts
wherever
i was i was waiting i was waiting i said
i left that opening let's see
how fast i am it's just his thank you
well as soon as i said it i was like oh
that's i left an opening there
but yeah so we always have we get those
big bags of uh like walnuts
and almonds and stuff like that from sam
so we always have nuts and that's kind
of like my favorite
thing to put on ice cream because that
like i said i don't like it it's i'll
eat it just plain
but i would rather there be like some
chunks in there
same with candy bars you could always go
down into the produce section and see
to see if they got fresh strawberries
even just the frozen strawberries throw
sugar on them a little bit of
lemon and just let them turn into that
strawberry glaze i always have some
strawberry like that in there
for when i'm making strawberry
shortcakes if i want to make a shortcake
i'll do that
i actually i got berries in there now
but yeah cause you made it because
because you made very shortcake just a
couple days ago yeah
but just the that strawberry topping
could just go right into that vanilla
ice cream mix and just shake that in a
bag
that'd be really good i'm shaking this
[ __ ]
it's in the wrist it's like that shake
weight yeah yeah yeah
i don't understand how [ __ ] got
big i can imagine i could imagine
i can imagine seagal buying that you
know if i buy that thing
and i just sit there and just do this
i'll get big
just the one for you look at he's doing
that you know what i mean
and he's getting he's watching
television
and he goes hey baby come over here
here you do it
see he's got her yeah it seems to be
working
oh my god it's funny well wouldn't that
does that seem like something seagal
might try to rationalize
yes you get the women to do your
exercises for you well yeah
that's like something yeah i'm getting
tired come here baby you do this
it's like yeah i'm feeling the burn
she's over there
[Laughter]
oh god keep going
well like you said he got he gets those
people to walk up down the steps and
it's like you know
cut bringing the double stair double
[ __ ]
they got it they got another dude that's
about his size but just a little bit
smaller going up and down yeah
i don't want him to see my fat ass going
downstairs
i didn't go i don't get paid to go up
downstairs these are my movies
that's above his pay grade yeah oh my
god so funny all his new [ __ ] every time
they shoot him it's just from the chin
up
they have to have some kind of dead
excuse to have his body covered up
yeah it's funny
pretty soon it's just going to be his
head on like a big pin cushion or
something pretty soon it'll just be
a cg version to him
he does the voiceover no he hires
somebody else to do the voiceover
because of some of the some of his
movies
it's not even his voice yeah he got
he's got a stunt double for his voice
hurt my throat
[Laughter]
look man [ __ ] this is supposed to be
a show about making our ice cream and
i'm getting off like a stevie's skull
again but like what else is there
should we go ahead and [ __ ] wrap guys
said crepe suzette with cream and
strawberries goddamn it i haven't had
that in a long time
yeah when i was in st augustine there
was a crepe restaurant there and i
really really wanted to try it but i
just didn't get it i just didn't have
time so next time i go i'm definitely
gonna just you could say i [ __ ] love
crepes
you could say [ __ ] all that fresh [ __ ]
and just make pancakes and do the exact
same thing just make a thinner pancake
well i do you spread it out a little bit
when i make pancakes i make them like i
put more milk
in that than the recipe calls for
because i like them thin i don't like
those big fluffy dense
yeah i don't like this big fluffy dense
pancakes i like them i mean i'll eat
them but it's like it's not my favorite
i'd rather have like i'd rather have
kind of thin crispy ones like more like
a crepe
yeah it's like just thin it out with a
little bit more water
like i said that's how i usually make it
i used to make
i used to make um like a low-fat version
like with uh
skim milk but i put like more skim milk
in there than it asked for
and then i'd like put spray probably
what they're doing in france
by the zeo pancake mix yeah
twice the water twice well like i said
it would be a lot easier yeah yeah
when i was in uh high school or junior
high or whenever whenever i took um
[ __ ] uh homeek they we actually made
crepes and they had actually had crepe
makers
in the class like the you know the
little hot thing that you turn it
something like that
it's like man that was a [ __ ] you get
yeah get the hang of
but we figured it out yeah zach said uh
waffles and ice cream
yeah i used to even i used to get like
those eggo waffles and you toast them
and then you put like some ice cream on
top of it and like make a little
sandwich
like uh with it i got like a warm egg
and waffles with ice cream in the middle
like uh yeah we used to do that when we
were kids that's [ __ ] delicious
i didn't put like syrup on it or nothing
because i'm not that crazy yeah i wanted
to mention whipped cream in case
you losers don't know i don't know how
to make that you just get some [ __ ]
cream
you can add a little bit of sugar to it
if you want to you don't have to but you
can add a little bit of sugar to it and
dissolve it
put it in a bowl and just take it with a
high speed mixer and eventually it'll
woo
it'll turn into whipped cream and when
it does stop
stop it stop it stop it as soon as it
becomes [ __ ] whipped cream stop
don't try to get [ __ ] fancy all right
you keep [ __ ] whipping it'll go
boom and turn right into right into
butter
and if there's sugar in it you won't
can't use it sugary butter
[Laughter]
that might be okay maybe for some things
for waffles and stuff
yeah they're probably be good probably
right sweet butter yeah i wouldn't put
it on a baked potato though
yeah it might be a little weird yeah and
then you just [ __ ] lost all your
[ __ ]
cream so but uh yeah it's easy to do you
don't even need electric
mixers some people can do it with a
whisk but it'll [ __ ] your
it'll [ __ ] your wrist up well it's like
the shake weights that's how you get
your exercise you know they used to make
it by hand back in the old days before
electricity
yeah and they and they liked it they
didn't complain about it nowadays you
[ __ ]
losers with your everything machine it
ass [ __ ] electronic machine
doing everything i totally just said
machinery yeah the machine
she's what she's laughing at is my dad
[Laughter]
my dad one time i was visiting my dad i
was in my 20s at that time you know i
was
back from the army he's going out where
where'd he go
this is where what go my ear digging
machine
i said ear digging machines yeah my ear
[ __ ]
my ear digging mechanism
so i was [ __ ] picturing like
something like you know like an electric
toothbrush you know i mean that but
and he goes there it is he pulled it and
it was a [ __ ] bobby pin
i said that's the ear digging machine
here yeah this is ear digging yeah he's
in there digging his ear his
eyes are [ __ ] rolling down yeah
[Laughter]
that's not a [ __ ] machine he goes
yeah
so he started arguing about i said
machine's got to have moving parts
it is moving
because my hand's going to make it still
moving
yeah he's so [ __ ] funny yeah well how
do
we were talking about that last night
because i can't remember how he got on
that topic because i saw a tampon
assertion machine oh that's right yeah
because we're outside the club like wait
a minute i immediately talked about it
in my dad's terminologies
just stay away from that that's a tampon
insertion machine
without even thinking i said it he's
like wait what are those really called
what's that really called the
application yeah yeah yeah i know it was
i don't think it was used i think it
was like the tampon was still in the
yeah and i tried to kick it i
tried to kick it out of the way in front
of the door and then [ __ ] it hit our
little [ __ ] friend and her [ __ ]
high heel shoes
i was like good job
so watch out
they put the dick on me last night i was
at the [ __ ] bar
i was talking to the vegan black metal
chef and i hear some people giggling and
laughing and looking over my shoulder
and they [ __ ] took a towel and had it
all wrapped up and folded it looked like
a deck on my shoulder
it [ __ ] fell i got it on video that's
one of dimitri's great town yeah yeah
he can take a bar towel and fold it and
turn it into a
dick well the funny thing about it was
that he was he was over there fully
because he [ __ ] it up the first time
yeah and because i was watching him like
snickering
and then like so he then finally he did
it and he laid it on your shoulder
yeah and you didn't realize it for a
really long time and i'm sitting there
going
yeah there's no way that he doesn't know
that there's like a big dick on his
shoulder but so we were all like [ __ ]
cracking up because he didn't notice i
didn't notice
yeah i got it on video [ __ ] oh did
you edit
your videos
that wasn't like the best towel dick
that demetri ever made but it's pretty
good
you see they got a damn dick on my
shoulder
i'm talking to vegan black girl yelling
i'm in full leather daddy mode at the
club
i'm [ __ ] yelling i'm yeah i'm talking
about making pizza right there and then
i turn something's on my shoulder
something's on my shoulder and i look
over
and the [ __ ] falls off and they were
[ __ ] laughing at him
okay that's how they did it i couldn't
believe that that was on there
[ __ ] put the dick on me i
didn't even know like matt it was just a
really funny
what the [ __ ] is that
see that was a long time so yeah i
didn't know about it so
i looked down and saw that [ __ ] and they
were [ __ ] laughing
so i reached down there and got it
i reached down there and got it and
opened my fly and stuffed it in there so
it's hanging out on top
cause i'm never gonna let this [ __ ]
win so i was just walking around with
that [ __ ] hanging out of my [ __ ] fly
like
that [ __ ] was like that big you know
actual size
that's the close representation
something
and i was talking and i was talking [ __ ]
to people i forgot i had it
and a group of hot chicks walked around
the bar and suddenly oh
they were shocked and i was like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i didn't i don't care
and that was like that was really early
in the night so we hadn't even really i
think we were just on our first drinks
yeah so it wasn't even i don't give a
[ __ ] that was like sober shenanigans
yeah oh my god yeah i can't guys say
there's a whole towel folding thing at
disney resorts hotels yeah i kind of
feel like fancier hotels have a whole
yeah towel folding thing i i don't know
if they're going to fold them to look
like dicks
i guess they would if they didn't like
you just like believe in dick
if you're like an [ __ ] to them
they'll just fold it like a decade
[Laughter]
alongside a tampon insertion machine
exactly he wants to hear my dad's real
voice i'd just call him and put him on
the phone
he was the last time i talked to him i
talked to him for father's day yeah a
couple days
and he fully he fully has
he's like yeah that was back when i used
to put the chicken with
the turkey necks and everything that was
back in that time
says and i said yeah that was a weird
[ __ ] because i fully believed it at the
time
[Laughter]
that i was on that trip you know that
that was the trip i was on that's what
he said
that was the trip i was on yeah yeah
back in these days when i thought i was
full of turkey take an accident
he got abducted by a cult that had
abducted him
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] he was dripping
well you know anesthetics are a hell of
a drunk ice
yes oh my god
well i'm about tired of my morning i
know i'm like [ __ ] exhausted
yeah we just like uh we didn't leave the
club that late last night but
we did we drank a lot and we had we had
a good time
i think i remember you guys ate pizza
and then i was just kind of like i
didn't really want pizza but then like
when we were getting home i was like nah
[ __ ] man i want a quarter pounder so i
made him go to mcdonald's and give me a
quarter pounder i don't know what these
people talk about
what you talking about no need for me
what oh i guess he just got
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah actually uh jenny
did the
jenny lifted the design didn't you that
was just the one that was out there in
the in the phantom sphere for that
i think oh it yeah or it was a variation
of one that was but i just like remade
it you just kind of remade it yeah
um but yeah we got uh i got to make him
some more shirts too i got like the pink
ones and i got the cat and the dog
yeah but i think there's one more size
i'm waiting on right we're going to run
a little small
batch for some people who needed some
stuff it's a private order so we're
going to do it
by the end of the month and we're going
to get them out by the end of the month
yeah it should be
because it's not very many no we're
talking about it's like under 10
yeah or under under 15. yeah it might
only be like 10 churches yeah
all right yeah i really have to go uh
take a nap so actually i don't
i can't take a nap yet but i'm gonna go
get some coffee and stay awake and then
i'll take a nap
yeah but yeah so uh it's tuesday so
tomorrow
is uh sidetracked yeah okay so we'll be
uh damn we gotta drink again
[ __ ] this our little livers are like
yeah because we went out saturday night
and we went out last night yeah
and uh every other day it's just like
but that's just because certain [ __ ]
aligned
yeah it's just an alignment of the
planets
in the alignment of the alcoholic
planets
that's how that worked yeah we'll uh
i'll try not to
drink too much tomorrow that's why i'm
definitely not going to drink tonight
because
i ordered this big ass [ __ ] water
filter from brazil like how we
i grew up with when i was living in
brazil it's called a song joao or saint
john
all right cylinder one's a company that
makes it and it's made out of clay
all right it's got a it's got a big
it's got a bottom jug with a spigot
media clay and then it's got a top jug
with a valve
control in the bottom of the top jug and
then it's got a
um lid and in that top jug it's got a
filter that screws in there it's got all
these rubber gaskets
now filter looks like just a solid piece
of damn
white porcelain i don't know how it
works man but it works great you could
put dirty water in the top
and it just goes somehow goes through
that
piece of porcelain it's like a porcelain
cylinder you don't see any holes in it
or anything it looks like it's high
gloss
somehow water goes through there and
when it comes out the other it just
drips
so it'll hold like three gallons in the
top and three gallons in the bottom
and as you're taking it out of the
bottom it's it's hitting the valve and
allowing the stuff
the dirty water in the top to go through
the filter it was expensive man they
don't make anything like that here
but it the water goes through the uh
the clay and it stays wet on the outside
so it's always cool even at room
temperature
and magic yeah does it and they use them
in brazil because you can't drape tap
water there
yeah uh but you know it doesn't filter
very fast but it can filter a lot of it
you're not watching it all the time so
you always have like on hand like three
gallons of this
water and it [ __ ] tastes really good
it tastes like mineral water like it
came out of a damn spring
yeah yeah it tastes really good yeah
that it does take a long time but yeah
but we have a we have a bread
brita pitcher as well and we have the
filter thing in the
in the refrigerator the freezer the
freezer door right but you know because
this is
hurricane area and everything you
i want to have the ability to [ __ ]
purify waters you know in pretty big
scales if i have to
you know because we got ponds right here
if we ever lose power
and the pumps to the water supply goes
which that happens here
i can go down there with a bucket and
get some water yeah pond water
yeah and pour it in there get all the
tadpoles
out of there if i can run it through a
strainer and uh it'd come out like
fresh spring water it might taste a
little bit like alligators but
now i would it would
this water tastes like alligators yeah
all the sentences i never thought i'd
say out loud well they're pissing in
there and they're [ __ ] in there so
you know
you know it's going to taste bad it's
going to have some kind of
body fluid [ __ ] taste for damn well
like i said there's not really much you
can do about because
you know you gotta drink water and yes
fish [ __ ] in it
yeah they [ __ ] in it so what are you
gonna well i guess technically fish
don't really [ __ ] in it
all right actually it's worse than that
because most of the time they just lay
eggs and then the other fish comes and
sprays jizz all over the eggs yeah
grams want to know how much it cost this
because he's a cop and he prepares for
the [ __ ]
inevitable also um the problem with it
wasn't the cost of the filter the filter
itself wasn't that much it was
after after all the conversions it was
you know
probably 50 60 bucks the problem was the
shipping
it's it's fragile and it came all the
way from brazil
and shipping was almost 100 bucks still
though that's not
that bad for as big as it is yeah and
it's fancy as it is
yeah i mean that's not i thought you
were gonna say it maybe yeah or
something maybe oh somebody sent it
got a super chat from no need for me too
five dollar super show oh awesome just
showing some love kind of
slow at the moment but love the shows i
missed too much going on to share it all
right thank you very much
thank you very much maybe when i get a
chance i'll post uh
i'll post a link to that water filter
yeah okay
it's pretty handy yeah like i said i
thought i grew up just drinking water
out of the tap so it's like it doesn't
really bother
me that much um although you cook with
that kind of water it depends on like
where
you're at because most of the time the
waters taste fine but it's like i lived
in one place where the water tasted not
bad but it just tasted like grass
yeah people are moving up here a lot of
them from new york you know they're
building these [ __ ] huge apartments
we passed them yesterday
downtown they're building these
concentrations camp style [ __ ]
apartments they're spending a lot of
money
why the [ __ ] do you want to live in that
you move to
you move away from new york to come to
florida and you want to live in that
why'd you just stay in new york you know
what i mean but
for the amount of money that they're
[ __ ] spending it just doesn't make
sense to me but well some people don't
like to live i mean well they don't like
to live
because the house is a lot of
maintenance you have to do the lawn you
have to do all this and
do it and do in the lawn in florida is a
pain in the ass and i can see like
wanting to live near downtown because
everything is close by
walk places i believe in spreading the
[ __ ] out don't well i know but i'm just
saying some people don't like that
don't like to do that i don't i don't
particularly like to have to do yard
work that's why we have a lawn service
yeah we got dudes to do that had to
worry about it but i do like i do like
being
um really close to everything and like
not having to
like drive places being in that damn
cracker box though
probably costs more than what we're
paying here and that includes all well
i'm sure it is because it's right in
downtown right yeah
yeah i mean that was but like i was
telling um tiff the bartender last night
i said i think that was my favorite
thing
about my vacation at st augustine was
that i could walk everywhere
yeah i got there i parked the car and i
didn't drive the car i'm just not
i'm just not you know this i'm in
downtown mentality that never
you know i was i was like i lived like
that in boston it just never really
[ __ ]
i never really gave a [ __ ] a lot like i
said i like it i like being like within
walking distance of a bunch of stuff
i kind of like to be away from these
[ __ ] and then you drive to it
when you want it
you know i mean you can go there if you
want to and then you can get away from
it
yeah that's i i like it but um
what was i talking about i don't know
how it should happen
oh just saying that they're that they're
building
um the water okay what i was saying was
i said that people moving here from new
york
you know i'll see them comment like on
youtube videos about florida
and they they're they moved here and
they [ __ ] have total misunderstanding
of the florida and south
the water is so bad here and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are they talking about
and some of these counties somewhat like
places out in eustis they got hard water
that's probably what they're [ __ ]
talking about maybe because
even here we have hard water because it
turns our shower orange yeah you gotta
wash it out you have to clean the shower
like bleach the shower out all the time
because
it just turns the whole bottom of the
shower in the wall orange and the
concept of
iron and i guess the concept of
filtering your water before you drink it
is an alien concept to
somebody in new york although i wouldn't
[ __ ] trust water coming out of the
tap in new york city
[ __ ] no i think i dr when i was without
that [ __ ] i just you know it's like i
could imagine what the inside of those
pipes look like i've been down to that
kind of [ __ ] before
well you can i mean the thing though is
that it's really cheap now like i said
you can get a brita
water pitcher or you can get like a
little filter that fits on your uh
on your sink thing most counties in
florida though have have good taste in
water though from what i've seen
i've only lived one place where the
water tasted funny it didn't taste bad
necessarily but it tasted like
like i said it tastes like grass yeah
you know what i mean like it tasted like
it had been sitting in the grass or
those grasses
so not a terrible taste but not like
water
and some people have wells where it's
pumped out in the country it's pumped
directly out of the water table
well my grandmother's house had a well
yeah for a long time so there's no water
system and she was in daytona beach or
holly hill more specifically
some people aren't even on a sewage
system per se they just have a septic
tank
yeah my grandmother's house always had
it might still have it i'm not really
sure
and a lot of mississippi was like that
yeah when i was a little kid one of the
first things that [ __ ] they told me
when i was a little kid don't open those
manhole covers
every little house had a manhole cover
in the back of it in the backyard
that's the septic tank that's how you
get into there they because they
they do open it and they pour stuff down
in their bacteria and stuff to [ __ ]
eat everything up yeah
so you have to maintain them but you
know this idea that you have to be on
some kind of city support grid you don't
have to
you just want to make sure that septic
tank never leaks because you might be
pumping
pumping water out of the same water
table and you don't want to you don't
want your septic tank to
contaminate contaminate your dab water
supply so it's got to be sealed off
but i [ __ ] had water pump right out
of the ground with electric pumps
um well that one barn that i used to
work at did it
and that was in eustis and it [ __ ]
great water right out of the water table
and um in mississippi some of it just
comes right out of the water
there's no water only the towns have a
water department
yeah you're out of town that's what was
so weird about where my grandmother
lived because it was like a residential
neighborhood it was built in the 50s
but she always had a septic tank i guess
because
she was like her address was holly hill
but i guess it was a little bit
of land that was unincorporated so she
always had a septic tank and like
grantham's hammer said the tank has to
get pumped every five years or so yeah
that sounds about right
they had to come and pump it like every
and then it would like stink up the
whole neighborhood it probably depends
on where you're at though gramps there's
some of those
some of those mississippi houses they
had they never did that it depends on
how i guess it depends on how big the
how big the step to take is and and how
many people are living in that house
i do remember that they'd go back there
with like a 50-pound bag of damn
chemicals in back and i think it had it
was enzymes and bacteria and stuff
and they'd pour that into that manhole
cover every few years
and um it would eat all that stuff up
yeah yeah and it you didn't smell
anything
i guess it just kept all the gases
trapped i guess so or it vented them so
slowly
maybe it vented them up through a
charcoal filter or something i don't
know you never smelled anything
interesting they knew how to make them
and they were old that was [ __ ] from
like i said the 50s
yeah that's what hers was because the
house was built in 58 yeah and hers was
one of the first houses
it was like three her there was a she
lived on a corner and it was her house
and there were
the four other corners if you're in a
place that has a low population density
it doesn't
economically make sense to [ __ ] pipe
that whole thing for sewage and pump it
out to some treatment plant just treat
it in place well i think that that's
that's why her house had that because it
was just kind of like
you know everything built up around it
but when they moved there there wasn't
that much there right right in the
beginning in the early days it was
real sparse population you just it's not
worth it to [ __ ]
run pipes out there with four houses
yeah because that's all there was for a
long time we're getting off topic though
and this is what kind this what kind of
ice cream show is this we're talking
about septic
i know how does this happen i [ __ ] me
man
it is you it is yeah i'm taking it for
that [ __ ] okay well that's
that's good at least and the [ __ ]
storm is coming yeah
we got a storm i got a new jam generator
that'll run this whole house
and the central air and everything and
all the refrigerators
i got that [ __ ] sitting up there in a
dime box and i gotta [ __ ] break that
motor in
yeah add oil to it and get it all
running i mean they'll we might have to
they might have to use it if we get a
hurricane this year you just roll the
damn generator out there it's on wheels
plug it into the side of the house where
the power box is fire that [ __ ] up it's
his push button
i'll sit back in here with [ __ ]
internet and ac
and [ __ ] refrigerators and [ __ ] watch
all these [ __ ] suffer
[Laughter]
turn them lights off feel like you can
put the porch lights on
totally normal they sit back there
you're just gonna do that like that on
the front
front porch [ __ ] smoking them herbal
cigarettes like that
how y'all doing every single light in
the house on
yeah staying cool hot out isn't it
that's right [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you're a charmer i know man i don't
understand it
all right yeah you said you said it was
going to be a short joke because we're
retired and it's almost an hour long
yeah but yeah we better go because i
think the uh power might start to flash
in a minute because
it could the storm's getting better it's
hard to say let me see what people are
saying though
see if they're [ __ ] with me from
vermont okay talk about something okay
go ahead
go ahead go ahead go ahead we shut it
down all right yeah all right so
uh thanks everybody for dropping by
thank you no need for me too for your
super chat
and uh we will see you guys tomorrow at
5 pm est for
our drunken sidetrack show so that's
always fun
so have a good rest of your day you guys
bye oh